ciao ragazzi siamo guglielmo ancora con
ancora seriosa ciao ragazzi e benvenuti
un nuovo episodio di intervista
quadrupla tra fratelli io sono cogliamo
enrico marcello macchina jennifer lopez
per giocare un gioco che va molto di
moda all'estero dopo aver mal di schiena
non ho mai in italiano che ci verranno
fatte le domande qualche state raccolte
tramite instagram
se voi non l'avete mai fatto allora
mettiamo il rosso davanti
provateci non ho mai fatto invece una
cosa che avete fatto mani col di
mettiamo verde questo vuol dire mi
avvalgo della facoltà di non rispondere
si mette anche le labbra vestito tutto
il mio bargoni ad ora chiedo perché
guarda lì non capisco proprio a
strizzare sui legni e poi che avvalerti
della facoltà pre mondiali avete mai
cacciato per strada io sono un capo a
casa milan
avete mai tradito mi aveva pure vero che
questi se non una fidanzata nell'albero
di fatto è che sono dei ragazzi si
sarebbero apparsa la facoltà rispettata
leggi sentita solo che da sei anni
allora ecco il lavoro e torino per me
avete mai usato lo spazzolino dell'altro
e li ammazzo avete mai detto ti amo
senza mare e non ho fatto altro
avete mai rubato in un negozio a un
rotolo di scotch ero bambino io ho
rubato un polipo al reparto del resto è
messo in tasca aveva avete mai baciato
una persona del vostro stesso sesso
quindi avete mai quindi se tu evasione
del sesso con i di attore
il griko omosessuale sai che una volta
per sbaglio tu mettessi un bacio non
avete mai fatto una cosa a tre ma i
russi così questa domanda che invece
gabriele che tale detto al video prima
avete mi ha fatto il vento al ristorante
queste cose non si fanno che ti dico sì
che oppure lo ricordando che avete mai
avuto una liaison con un personaggio
famoso davvero e chi hai mai incolpato
un fratello per qualcosa che hai fatto e
non lo ricordo ma di sicuro il colpo
perché lo volete rendere boromei vostro
pl botte solitamente e chi le merita
no perché ha fatto qualcosa di sbagliato
perché è stato tanto stupido hai mai
avuto una storia con un fan non
disdegniamo le fan
sposiamoci avete mai provato attrazione
per il partner dell'altro hai mai fumato
una canna tarda età e mi ha lasciato
molto deluso perché pensavo che fossero
un qualcosa di molto più assurdo smesso
perché mi facevano aumentare hai mai
imprigionato in cui facevo altro che una
ragazza che vede un ragazzo super carino
ben disposto e competitiva realtà
ragazzo piace il fratello hai mai fatto
sesso nel letto di un fratello mamma mia
che abominio gabriele se il mio ti
ammazzo
sapete che il mio letto è rotto che sia
negli occhi avete mai fatto una rissa
poesie
avete mai illuso in amore che noi a
gianluigi enrico stiamo parlando dei
criceti mitica criceti di commentare i
conti con atto anche attrice tv di casa
bella frase più pagati oggi criceti nidi
carcere di casa mette the likes avete
riempito il tc casa guardate vostra
sorella quella santocchia che sta lì
accanto a baby sempre più una criceti na
di casa parte delle stories su instagram
l'azienda chiave quali fatevi i ceti
medi mentre la rosso man mano la
valigetta di casa e vuole fare la
perfettina con bambino avete mai avuto
esperienze paranormali è una bella
domanda mi piace bravi ho i brividi
ho i brividi per quel che è successo a
me sono successe cose guarda guarda che
c hai mai preso un palo in amore ma
fanno molto male la moglie si è mai
finto di essere al telefono per evitare
qualcuno in strada sensore che senti
quello che aveva portato a 100 carcere
ripasso periodo però non portava gli
occhiali quindi si può preso alla
sprovvista no che mi sembrava un oscuro
shooter operativo lo avete mai usato la
popolarità di gu per rimorchiare verde
avete mai fatto sesso alcun appuntamento
avete mai mangiato cibo scaduto da più
di un mese quante volte mi tiravano in
bocca che la canzone poi paio camion
frigo veramente cimitero
quindi sì io non bevo il latte che è
stato manco da un giorno mi chiedo
perché c'è bambina che trova a comprare
a fungere da rookie agrigentino di
correre presto ai mai mentito di un
fratello per il suo bene però è
importante dire che avete mai fatto
ghosting un po smetti di rispondere a
una persona senza cedere comparsa sa già
di chicago sting a metà le voleva dire
ignoti tende frequentazioni a chiunque
io faccio costing anche a loro cioè
difesa a volte rispondere quello che
voglio dire io invece spesso hai mai
pensato di essere il più intelligente o
ancor peggio di un presuntuoso un finto
umile specie se un cretino
posso dire però che ha mai calcato in
testa un piccione volta sono stato
mitragliato mia testa
sei mai stato bocciato
[Musica]
metti quel verde miniere nome quello che
è successo qualcosa
e come per magia abbassano le manda
avanti e diventa verde ma se non sono
entrato all'inizio e resta volatile
essere respinti deve essere sbocciato
hai mai corteggiato qualcuno molto più
giovane o vecchio di ten sia
assolutamente immigrati giovani va
benissimo tutto non è l'età il problema
il problema è hai mai mangiato
iniziativa ma non ho mangiato locuste
esce con domanda ovvero di una razza del
cambio di moria davanti
involontariamente buonanotte a domanda
bisogna alzare queste ma ragazzi ma a
quello vanno come cantava alla proposta
e grilli per milardo e tutto quanto
siamo detto buonissimi una casa faceva
la ricerca
avete mai spiato il telefono dell'altro
ragazzo su cui lavorare
domani per queste le leggi dure fatto
già qui e non l'ho fatto
un altro era successo quella volta che
guglielmo mi chiede un telefono dopo
mesi liquidi la chat che si riempì boom
di messaggi e dopo aver letto un po capì
che non erano messaggi
avete mai fatto una pazzia per amore si
arrabbia davvero via cover che appaiono
drammatica rispondere quando ci si
innamora davvero le pazzie non sono il
mio così assurda però insomma così si
ricev iniqua sottolineandone giardino
che non voleva rispondere trecentesca
cefalù mano la loro pazzi stata correre
velocissimo sulla ruotato in tre
cecchini scappa dalla gabbietta unito e
lo quando si rivedranno nel video di
rozzano che se ne seguì che voi siete
due crescente che per amore hanno fatto
come fanno i precetti divorato il
partner corrono valori religiosi si sono
messi i comodi
però noi ci siamo se socialmente e
lavorati ragazzi cosa che mi
qui c'è una divisione da chi
fortunatamente ha trovato l'amore e chi
sfortunatamente la ricetta ha trovato
l'amore chi sfortunatamente sta con
colture bene si conclude così il leader
ragazzi siamo eletti alla fine di questo
video estate la paletta per farmi sapere
semplice divertiti alzate la maretta chi
non ha mal di schiena
questo video spero che mi abbia
divertito l'intervista 4 per una cosa
che ogni tanto ci chiedete specialmente
su instagram è sotto nei commenti
ringrazio anche gabriele gianluigi e
arrigo o se preferite enrico marciano e
luigi detto ciao ragazzi ci vediamo
questa domenica con un episodio di
cucinare buttano tutti insieme ciao
quindi descrive gli scudi c'è il livello
basso milioni di merda